[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le but c'était de données que je vous ai
agi du plateau de satory eau est une
autre alternative pour pouvoir se
mouvoir cette alternative à les données
par les navettes automne aux framboises
et litchi ses navettes et sont
accessibles à tous à tous les usagers à
tous les visiteurs et les salariés du 2
du plateau ce service et ses navettes
vont notamment desservir plusieurs
arrêts l'art et nexter l'arrêt psa
motorsport l'arrêt arcus et enfin le
mobile à bhl qui a tout d'abord une
application qui va permettre de
géolocaliser les navettes et donc de
pouvoir également donc les commandes et
il va y avoir également un steward qui
va être à bord et qui va permettre
notamment de pouvoir guider les
différences d'usagé dans ce nouveau mode
de transport et enfin la navette l
équipé de plusieurs éléments plusieurs
capteurs qui permettent de la
géolocaliser et également d'assurer un
service et un transport en toute
sécurité
l'objectif c'est également d'avoir une
perception est tendu donc de permettre
de voir ce qu'un conducteur classique ne
verrait pas à savoir des caméras qui
vont par exemple être placés à
différents endroits et qui vont être
connectés avec la navette lui permettant
d'adapter son comportement en fonction
de ce qui arrivera il y aura également
des feux connectés donc tout un ensemble
de dispositifs sur le bord de route qui
va améliorer le service
enfin c'est une expérience qui va durer
18 mois et qui va permettre de
comprendre les usages et donc les
comportements des usagers par rapport à
ces nouveaux modes de service
[Musique]